Secretary of the army I got to know him
very well and he's an outstanding guy
Pat Shanahan who is a wonderful person
is as you know going to take some time
off family matters and I want to thank
him for a service he's a terrific person
and it's a difficult time for Pat but
he's going to take a little time off for
family service and and for for working
working things out and I think you know
about it you know very well about it but
mark Esper is going to be outstanding
and we look forward to working with him
for a long period of time to come excuse
me no I didn't I didn't ask him to
withdraw but he walked in this morning
he said it's going to be a rough time
for him because of obviously what
happened but I did not ask him to
withdraw he presented me with a letter
this morning that was his that was his
decision
I had heard about it yesterday for the
first time I didn't know about it I had
heard about it yesterday and it's it's
very unfortunate very unfortunate now we
have a very good vetting process and you
take a look at our cabinet and our
secretaries very good but we have a
great vetting process but this is
something that came up a little bit over
the last short period of time and as you
know Pat was acting and so acting gives
you much greater flexibility a lot
easier to do things so that's the way it
is too bad
[Music]
why do you bring that question up now
it's an interesting time to bring it up
you have people on both sides of that
they admitted their guilt if you look at
Linda fair Steen and if you look at some
of the prosecutors they think that the
city should never have settled that case
so we'll leave it at that
no not at all I think frankly this could
happen very quickly for Marquess where
he's very experienced he's he's he's
been around all of the things that we're
talking about for a very long period of
time
well we have Iran we've been talking to
various people on lots of different
sides and we'll see what happens with
Iran we're very well set we're very well
configured we have a lot of things going
on with Iran
I spoke with President Xi this morning
of China will be meeting at the g20 and
I think that is working out pretty much
as I anticipated a would China very much
wants to discuss the future and so do we
so the relationship with President Xi is
a very good one we had a long talk this
morning they know and they're going to
start next week and when people come
into our country and they come in
illegally they have to go out and
everybody's seeing that and as you know
Mexico has been doing a very good job
the last four days they haven't done
that in 25 years they're doing a very
good job I appreciate the job they're
doing Guatemala likewise is much
different than it was under past
administrations so we'll see how that
works out with all of that being said
the Democrats should get together and
solve the asylum problem which is very
easy to solve and they should solve the
loophole problem also very easy to sell
well this came up this just came up and
I did the nomination it just came up and
I think we did it very quickly
Matt Shanahan was acting and we put Marc
esperan Marc is highly experienced I
think he's going to fit in very easily
[Music]
well let's see what he does I can tell
you that Draghi is the me you if you
look at what's going on with the euro
they have a much different stance that
our folks do as you know we did
something today that was very dramatic
and frankly it helped that part of the
world so we'll see what happens they're
going to be making an announcement
pretty soon so we'll see what happened
but I want to be given a level playing
field and so far I haven't been I would
be allowed to speak to it very easily I
speak to him anyway
[Music]
most likely that's what I'm thinking
about doing it most likely pretty soon
we're looking at Iran we have a lot of
things going with Iran we have we're
very prepared for Iran we'll see what
happens but let me just say this we are
very prepared regardless of what ghosts
we are very very repair prepared if you
look at what's taking place if you look
at what they've done if you look at and
I'm not just talking about over the last
week I'm talking about over a long
period of years they've been a nation of
terror now we'll see what happens
we'll see what happens they are a much
different country today than they were
two and a half years ago when I came
into office when President Obama signed
that horrible deal they were screaming
death to America I haven't been hearing
that lately
I have a meeting on that actually this
afternoon before my speech I'm going
down as you know to a very big crowd
down in Florida Orlando and before that
I'm having a meeting so we'll we'll be
letting you know well I have a very good
relationship with President Xi and we'll
see what happens I think we have a
chance I know that China wants to make a
deal they don't like the tariffs a lot
of companies are leaving China in order
to avoid the tariffs I have a very good
relationship with President Xi we'll see
what out
[Music]
what happens I think the meeting might
very well go well and frankly our people
are starting to deal as of tomorrow the
teams are starting to deal so we'll see
China would like to make the deal we'd
like to make the deal but it has to be a
good deal for everybody so I said we're
not going to do that
you're gonna find out you're gonna find
out thank you